the situation with North Korea is not
showing any signs of de-escalating
anytime soon Donald Trump continues to
throw the sort of belligerent and
erratic threats towards North Korea and
once again casually threatening genocide
of the North Korean people on Twitter
where he wrote over the weekend just
heard foreign minister of North Korea
speak at UN if he echoes thoughts of
little Rocketman they won't be around
much longer
and of course what Donald Trump is
referencing here was a speech by the
North Korean Foreign Minister Lee
young-ho who earlier the same day called
Trump a quote mentally deranged person
full of megalomania who is holding quote
the nuclear button happens to be a
perfectly accurate assessment of Donald
Trump not to cheerlead anything North
Korea does we we have our fair share of
criticism for North Korea but it seems
to be a sort of accurate assessment
remember last week at the United Nations
when Donald Trump had the following to
say the United States has great strength
and patience but if it is forced to
defend itself or its allies we will have
no choice but to totally destroy North
Korea Rocketman is on a suicide mission
for himself and for his regime yeah so
after that a bunch of people wrote to me
they said David you're not telling the
truth that's not a threat of genocide
that's just fake news is it let's
examine genocide of course design
defines as the deliberate killing of a
large group of people especially those
of a particular ethnic group or nation
saying you will totally destroy North
Korea or that as he said over the
weekend that North Korea won't be around
much longer is saying you're going to
destroy a large group of people from a
particular nation it is a de facto
threat of genocide and I believe this is
a loser's battle for Trump because North
Korea is lead as we know by an erratic
megalomaniac Kim jong-un the u.s. is
also led by an erratic Mangalam
where and if we imagine erratic
megalomaniacs getting together it's
usually not good for the average person
and North Korea's not backing down they
are keeping up the military threats
despite the warnings from trump the
minister of north korea the foreign
minister says that this tweet from
donald trump was a declaration of war
and that it now justifies military
action against american military assets
even outside of North Korean airspace
you need an adult in the room it used to
be Obama and there's no adult in the
conversation right now so just on this
definitions point about genocide it did
strike me at first as maybe not the most
appropriate term but then you take a
look at that definition and you think
that well I think usually it's because
you think of a genocide is something
that a government does internally some
say like the Holocaust the Armenian
Genocide Darfur but it doesn't
necessarily have to be that when you
talk about a nation that's being
targeted when you talk about a political
entity that's being targeted
I think that fits quite a pro I think
the term absolutely applies and it's
what Donald Trump is threatening on
Twitter we have a president in 2017 who
is who is threatening the wholesale
destruction of a nation on Twitter and
Kim jong-un is bananas right I mean the
guy's executed members of his own family
nevermind countless civilians he may
well be geopolitically suicidal maybe
not but the last thing you want is
someone else who's just as much of a
hothead opposing that outrageous hothead
megalomaniac Trump doesn't seem to have
any ability to calm down Pyongyang just
released more videos showing us planes
and an aircraft carrier under attack so
it's all escalating and there's a very
disturbing article from The New Yorker
which puts this fiasco into context and
it points out there's never been a
moment in history when you had two
national leaders both of whom have
nuclear weapons at their disposal and
it's it's the geopolitical equivalent of
a penis size contest now you might hear
me say this and say okay well David
listen Trump's nuts Kim jong-un is nuts
but how do you deal with North Korea
right now the threats don't seem to work
the sanctions barely seem to work
leaning on China doesn't seem to work so
then what do you do there aren't really
what one would call good options
particularly when the more
that North Korea receives from other
countries the more they seem justified
in their desire for nuclear weapons
there's one analysis in the Atlantic by
Mark Bowden who says listen because the
options are bad you've got you know a
huge strike to totally destroy North
Korea a more strategic strike which also
has issues associated with it
huge sanctions mostly hurt the people of
North Korea who were trying to help what
about the Givet time strategy and what
Mark Bowden means is maintain the status
quo yes Kim jong-un can advance
development of weapons but he can't
really use those weapons unless he wants
to commit instant suicide right if and
when he uses a nuke he is assuring his
own destruction and Bowden argues listen
if the Kim family were that crazy they'd
probably have taken some action under a
previous administration they are now in
their third generation of rule by the
dictatorial Kim family and they seem to
have some control over themselves that's
one idea another idea is from someone
I'm actually not a fan of remember
former Bush lawyer John you involved in
this viral video where he refused to
answer John Conyers questions about
whether the president could legally
order a prisoner be buried alive during
questioning John you says cut the status
quo and cyber hack your way to a
solution
he says use technology to [ __ ] the
North Korean regime and some of the
ideas that John u has are freeze the
assets of North Korean companies leaders
everyone in banks around the world
because there are North Korean companies
and individuals that do have assets
around the world freeze them hack into
and disrupt companies that do business
with North Korea start using drones in
any number of ways Jam North Korean
satellites in space I don't know whether
these would be considered peaceful
tactics in the 21st century those are
probably acts of war but the idea is
make it clear to North Korea that
they're outmatched by crippling their
access to funds and technology which
they do need and and I'm not a fan of
John you but it's an interesting
suggestion that he
and we've heard over and over again that
there's really no good military option
when it comes to North Korea yes I think
any third way like those that John you
was pointing out it's good idea at least
a think about actually saw a pullout of
NPR asking Americans if the US president
wanted to launch a nuclear strike but do
you have to go get approval from
Congress first we have to consult with
Secretary of Defense or any of his
military generals and a plurality of
people thought that he would have to get
congressional approval which isn't true
if Trump decides to do it tomorrow he's
doing it tomorrow yeah at the end of
course it would be personally
hypocritical because Trump was the guy
when Obama was president saying oh no no
no no
President Obama can't even be
threatening to do the things he's
considering doing in Syria and in other
situations but we know that if Trump
makes the decision Trump is going to do
it I think that this is a very
interesting situation that we're finding
ourselves in with North Korea whatever
the solution though Trump's not the guy
I want at the helm Trump's not the guy I
want trying to figure it out today's
program is sponsored in part by policy
genius life insurance can be confusing
it can be time-consuming and if there
ever is a payout you won't be around to
spend it but there is one company that's
making it a lot easier policy genius.com
is the place to learn about life
insurance compare quotes from America's
top life insurance providers and save up
to 40% off of your policy they've got a
simple user-friendly website that helps
you figure out exactly which policy is
right for you and it finds you the best
price and if you do have questions they
have a team of licensed experts waiting
to talk you through it no call waiting
no pressing a bunch of buttons to direct
your call you actually get customer
service and they don't just do life
insurance you can get health insurance
you can insure your pet you can protect
your home whatever you need if you've
been putting off life insurance or you
want to make sure the insurance you have
is the right insurance for you check out
policy genius.com today you can save 40%
just by comparing policies the quotes
are free there's no sales pressure there
is zero hassle go to policy genius calm
it is life insurance for the 21st
century